meal kit companies set out to disrupt
grocery stores and change the way we
cook at home now there's 382 of them in
the US almost a 3,000% increase from a
decade ago when they were just 13
despite industrywide growth the meal kit
model faces an obstacle you of all the
people who tried one of five major meal
delivery services in 2022 about 90%
canceled their subscription by the end
of the year human behavior is very
fickle especially when it comes to food
and beverage and now Blue Apron one of
the earliest players is selling this is
the economics of me
kits this graph shows the share of sales
in the US between the major meal kit
companies in 2022 sunbasket and Marley
spoon Inc have 2 and 3% blue apron and
home Chef took 6 and 12% while
hellofresh and its subsidiaries ate up
78% but no matter their size many of
these companies use the same key
ingredients to find and keep customers
price point convenience and
variety first get the customer meal kit
companies focus a lot on the price per
meal here's how I make fancy meals for
under $5 get $149 per meal our biggest
competitor are the offline Grocers which
is why hellofresh and home Chef say it's
cheaper to buy meal kits than to buy
groceries wherever you Source the
ingredients to do home cooking from
scratch yourself that's our competition
in some way way but what makes that
possible it's all about economies of
scale Brian Choy has done market
research on the food and beverage
industry for 15 years and he says that
when it comes to keeping prices low for
the consumer grocery stores have an
advantage over most mekit companies
because of the volume of product they
handle daily but similarly the meal kit
companies that are best positioned to
offer the lowest price point for
consumers are the biggest ones like
hellofresh economies of scale allow us
to get better pricing to get get a
better margin on the product and then to
reinvest parts of that margin either
into a better customer experience or
into lower pricing which means that at
times the company can compete on price
with Grocers but on a peral basis buying
the ingredients yourself from a grocery
store still tends to be cheaper
especially considering that you can
always buy fewer ingredients or go for
cheaper options whereas the minimum you
could spend on hellofresh and blue apron
in a week is
$60.95 $12.49 per meal at least before
discounts it's sometimes hard to get
people over the purchase barrier that's
why incentives are a key part of our
marketing or growth playbook for every
dollar that we spend on getting that
group of customers it takes us about 6
months to actually earn that dollar that
we invested back which makes the next
step all the more important keeping the
customer these are the customer
retention rates for the same five meal
kit companies in 2022 in less than a
year they all lost the vast majority of
the new customers that bought their
first meal kits in January one possible
reason everyone drops off the discounts
they're doing their own mental calculus
they're like wow $12 meal is very
different from the $4 you know based on
the promotional rate when you introduce
a product to someone at a severe
discount you may get more people to try
it but when the discount goes away and
they have to pay full price it may not
be worth that new price to them one
thing about the American Consumer is
they don't like dramatic change in
prices so how do companies get retention
rates up one way is to offer the
discounts again and hope that they
entice customers to return and another
is to add more convenience and variety
the biggest value proposition is the
convenience the big thing meal kits
offer to Consumers is a convenient way
to cook at home they ship to your door
and give you pre-portioned ingredients
for relatively simple recipes but when
you stack that vers versus the other
options that Avail for for consumers the
collective value proposition has
diminished significantly with
restaurants and grocery stores offering
delivery to your door it's hard for meal
kits to offer a unique convenience to
customers and getting pre-portioned
ingredients may be more convenient if
you want to cook for yourself but
Americans only cook an average of 4.5
meals at home per week but companies
across the meal kit industry are
expanding their offerings and one of the
common ones isn't a meal kit at all it's
just pre-made meals doctor has chefs
cook meals for you and then they deliver
them fresh to your house they have oven
ready meals with everything included and
Fast and Fresh meals that can be done in
15 minutes as you grow your customer
base and you grow your assortment you
also tend to give customers a lot more
choice and more Choice means you're more
likely to get customers to spend more
with your company but it's yet to be
seen how much these new offerings will
increase retention rates across meal kit
companies plus retention rates aren't
everything looking back at this chart
blue APR a sits slightly above the rest
Which choice says may be because it
offers slightly more options and
customization but blue apron's Revenue
has declined greatly since 2017 then
there's profit both hellofresh and Blue
Apron got off the ground by raising
hundreds of millions of dollars in
funding in 2017 they both went public
then their paths split blue apron's
Revenue has slowly declined with just a
slight increase during the industry's
pandemic boom hellofresh on the other
hand has been consistently profitable
since 2017 looking at its Revenue you
see constant growth even after the
pandemic shutdowns ended and people
could eat at restaurants again once you
establish yourself as the leader in that
space it becomes very very hard to be
disrupted because you need to solve a
lot of complex problems over and over
again to get to that position while both
faced Stark drops in their share prices
the New York Stock Exchange threatened
to delist Blue Apron after its stock
dipped below a dollar the company
shifted to an asset light model scaling
down and offloading many of its
operations to another company then it
announced its selling to wonder group a
food delivery startup and returned to
being a private company another key step
is to differentiate the barriers to
enter the mekit industry are fairly low
which is partly why there are so many
mekit companies today but the barriers
to scale and build a big business are
actually really high and why it's
important for each one to stand out if
it wants to survive take methodology a
small meal delivery company that started
in 2015 it doesn't offer meal kits at
all instead methodology sends out four
or 5 days worth of pre-made meals with
ingredients you're less likely to find
in other kits like nalis cacti and
persan our audience is basically who I
was when I started the business they're
really time starved so they don't have
time to cook healthy meals on week
nights and as far as their incomes most
are making in the several hundred
thousands if not more than that most
other companies compete at a price point
around $8 to $15 per serving without
discounts but methodology costs around
$17 to $30 per meal our sweet spot
actually is men who live on takeout cuz
they're already doing it three to four
times a week minimum they're spending 35
on average for meal and it doesn't offer
discounts at nearly the same rate as the
other companies the average discount for
methodology kit is 10% off a customer's
first week Newan says this model has
allowed the company to be profitable
from year two we have customers who have
spent over $100,000 with us because we
really are a lifestyle for our Target
customer we're operating in one of the
largest consumer categories out there
which is uh food at home so in my view a
large category will always attract sort
of like new business models new entrance
in the category and so on Grand View
research forecasts that the revenue
across the US meal kit industry will
reach
64.2 billion by 30 do I believe the
numbers I think they're probably a
little bit too optimistic I don't know
what the food industry will look like in
5 or 10 years but I do think that we can
play a really big role in shaping the
future of the food industry I think in
10 years we'll probably see one or two
major players in the industry still
operating in that space I'll also expect
to see some companies that have gone
bankrupt or acquired by some of the
larger
[Music]
there